do you have to calm yourself down in
social situations or you pretty no I say
what the [__] I want to say oh you do
and you keep it moving oh you keep it
moving yeah I'm 51 I've gotten to the
point where I pass gas in public so I
don't give a oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I do I'm not holding my gas for nobody
that [__] cramps myself you know by me
not farting over the last 40 years in
public caused me to get my gallbladder
removed so I'm not teing up no more my
organs what they said it was chicken I
said it was
gas
they said it was greasy food but I blame
it on me holding my
f let her rip let her rip yeah yeah we
love your organs you know what I mean
but do holding your cuz she's she's a
Nerf I'm a fart holder and I'm a Hider
you you went to nursing school yeah so
let me ask you something I always
thought that too it's a poisonous gas
inside your body right well it's just
like byproduct it's byproduct and if you
hold it in your body it can't be good it
doesn't feel good
how is a byproduct you didn't buy
it you bought the food the food yeah and
it turns into that [__] okay and holding
it is that healthy or no I I don't know
I don't know the answer to but it does
not feel good I'm almost trying to like
no your [__] it's that's why God gave
you that very small [__] so you can
fart in
silence that is true no no no you don't
fart loud you fart like popping popcorn
in a microwave that's all right God damn
yeah it's like it's like firecrack going
out yeah yeah that's my small and tight
you poop you fall like
PE is that what your booty
ho okay so it says when you block a fart
from escaping some of the gas can pass
through your gut wall and be reabsorbed
into your bloodstream from there it can
end up being exhaled through your lungs
coming out of your mouth oh [__] BR
[__] oh you do not want that you got
to let your fart out your ass no I rip
them I rip my rip we hear him he sound
like a balloon going
down yeah you know when you let the
balloon go when you don't blow
up how I mean how is your health do you
feel good I feel great I just I had
surgery about three weeks ago why damn
yeah I had my gallbladder oh that's
right so that's real yeah so um I feel
great now at first that [__] was hurting
I feel like I had swallowed a something
a little small person just stabbing me
in my stomach and so finally I went to
the doctor and I said my [__] stomach
hurt in my shoulder and they gave me an
xra and they said hey you got go g
Stones mhm so I had them removed it was
great good and it feels better now yeah
I'm still I still got a few stitches in
my stomach but I'm okay yeah yeah what
is what is gall stone it's just it
accumulates like over time it like
concentrates well you have a gallbladder
breaks down the fats that you eat oh I
see and so when you abuse them with too
much greasy [__] it swell up into like
kidney stones and they start to they can
kill you cuz they if you don't get them
out they'll [__] cut your stomach and
get out oh I see they're really pretty
have you seen them no the gall stones
they look like gemstones cuz they're
very kind of yellow pull them up y yeah
yeah W do you keep them that yeah those
are look like CRA they look
like I was going to say topaz but yeah
CRA yeah it looks like it does look like
crack crack yeah look like [__] what's
pretty about that yeah yeah yeah I don't
know it looks like a sh like little
caramel to pass oh yeah like caramel
yeah do anybody ever keep them I think
so yeah there we go there we go they
look like broken tooth yeah these ones
aren't that good looking a is good no a
does GH okay okay a uhuh yeah that GRE
that g is pretty yeah g is yeah G's nice
yeah g looks like look like a dick yeah
yeah anyway I I think you're wrong I
don't think they look good I I find them
pretty okay you ever seen one live I I
have seen them yeah they they're like
they have this like a greenish because
of like the all the bile they have like
a greenish yellow color what do youall
do with them I don't know what they do
with them I'm sure they just toss them
out cuz it's
biohazardous why is it Biohazard